lui c'était le taquin à d'embrun où je
pourrai naturellement
non
elle c'était la grogne
il promenait sa bonhomie bras ballants
vos mains dans les poches et sont avides
de bons amis suivaient ton dissonant les
cloches sans rythme elle le cam nul est
à grommelé des arguties il répond d'être
d'école lead il ripostait par des lasi
le tac à feu et dénis et la grognon
bouguenais la grenouille et éboué et le
cac40 un peu le tac a faisait des niches
et largue en bourgogne
la grogne on était beaucoup mais le taux
qui sont on connaît à 16 heures il était
poète qui lui causait de papillons
tutelle l'avait mal à la tête
café la télévision petite-terre étude
nous voyons tu n'es plus un gamin à ce
qu'il doit donc pendant cette poule et
suit tes pieds prend les patins
le tac a faisait déni et la grognon
beney la grogne ont été pour vous le
taquin sont un peu le daaka faisait des
et la grogne on connaît les grognons est
et bourgoin mais le temps qu'ils sont en
poney mais le taquin s'entremêlent
taquin sont abonnés il siffle et perles
de cristal pendant qu'elle mangeait des
cachets qui s'écriaient t'as vu l'étoile
répondait mettons cache nez elle ne
planait jamais plus haut que le plus hot
ses bigoudis et lui allongé sur le dos
rêvait de mille et une nuits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'était la grogne ans
ton sourire
ouais toujours bien
lui cette tlpe taquin le vainqueur de
dénis et l'art roman boulonnais la
grogne est dépendant de l'état que sont
un peu des nues
étant donné les roms étaient bons mais
ne taquin sont tamponnés le tec à cause
des niches et la renault connaît la
grogne
était bon mais nous taquin sont un peu
taquin se déniche et la gagne au bout
connaît les raids
[Musique]